Shure: 就你起床啊
Shure: You just got up?
Shure: 就你按时起床
Shure: You actually got up on time?
Tasha: 就我按时起床了
Shure: 对
Shure: 好管管你这两个室友啊
Shure: Okay, take care of your two businesses.
Shure:  我说管管你这两个室友啊
Shure: I mean take care of your two roommates.
Tasha: 他们两个还没起
Shure: 没起
Shure: Not up yet?
Tasha: 好他们比我还离谱
Alice:Lucy啊我们该戴眼镜了
Alice: Lucy, we should wear our glasses now.
Alice:啊没事
Alice: Oh, it's nothing.
Alice:我就提醒你一下
Alice: Just reminding you.
Alice:轩我们要戴眼镜了
Alice: Xuan, we need to wear our glasses now.
Shure:  出去给白水蛋吃
Shure: Go out and feed the egg whites.
Alice:鸡蛋
Alice: Eggs.
Alice:你是哦
Alice: Really?
Alice:没事
Alice: It's nothing.
Alice:你要煮几个
Alice: How many do you want to boil?
Shure:  倒多少
Shure: How much water?
Shure:  拿6个吧先
Shure: Let's take 6 first.
Alice:现几个
Alice: How many now?
Shure:  现在5个
Shure: Now 5.
Shure:  再拿一个
Shure: Take one more.
Alice:水太多了是吗
Alice: Is there too much water?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Is it?
Alice:嗯无所谓
Alice: Yeah, whatever.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it.
Alice:没有锅盖好像
Alice: Seems like there's no lid.
Shure:  what
Shure: What?
Shure:  有吧
Shure: There should be one.
Shure:  这个能盖上它不
Shure: Can this one cover it?
Alice:这个好脏
Alice: This is so dirty.
Jake: 成果如何
Jake: How's it going?
Shure:  叫醒了
Shure: Woke them up.
Shure:  哦我还没我还没洗漱
Shure: Oh, I haven't brushed my teeth yet.
Shure:  我想起来了
Shure: I just remembered.
Shure:  还有个煎锅吧
Shure: There's also a frying pan, right?
Alice:现在就煎吗
Shure: 恩
Shure:  我先刷刷吧
Shure: I'll wash it first.
Shure:  还可以
Shure: It's okay.
Alice:你会煎吗
Alice: Do you know how to fry?
Shure:  放心
Shure: Don't worry.
Shure:  长这么大还没饿死呢
Shure: I've grown up this much and never starved.
Shure:  绝对稳稳拿下好吧
Shure: We'll absolutely get this done, okay?
Alice:你要几个蛋
Alice: How many eggs do you want?
Shure:  啊咱们昨天是不是买那个面包来着
Shure: Ah, didn't we buy some bread yesterday?
Shure:  把那面包然后裹点蛋液煎了吧
Shure: Let's coat the bread with some egg and fry it.
Alice:面包在这吗不在吧
Alice: Is the bread here? I don't think so.
Alice: 面包
Alice: Bread.
Alice:红薯
Alice: Sweet potato.
Shure:  这个要不也煎上得了
Shure: How about we fry this too?
Alice:面包应该在上边
Alice: The bread should be up there.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  还有一袋在楼下
Shure: There's another bag downstairs.
Shure:  他说
Shure: He said...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  他说有一袋在楼下
Shure: He said there's another bag downstairs.
Alice:啥
Alice: What?
Alice:啥呀
Alice:嗯没有吧
Alice: Hmm, I don't think so.